Bon, c'est facile pour eux de faire ce qu'ils font car ils ont déjà ces bâtiments tellement grands.
Regardent l'équipe des travails qu'ils ont.
Ils ont beaucoup d'argent donc ils peuvent payer même certains diagres pour travailler à templants.
Voilà pourquoi l'église fonctionne comme ça, etc.
Non, ce n'est pas du tout la même chose.
Les tabernacles, ils comptaient déjà avec l'excellence du peuple avant que les temples soient institués.
Et toutes les familles et chefs des familles étaient engagés.
Et donc, ce n'est pas qu'ils ne peuvent que faire avec l'excellence ce qu'ils font car ils ont les ressources.
C'est car ils ont dès le départ, dès le petit commencement, travaillé avec tellement d'excellence
que Dieu petit à petit a rajouté et a honoré leur service, leur excellence.
Car quand on voit l'histoire de ces églises, donc MacArthur était là pendant 50 ans dans la même église locale.
Et si on va aujourd'hui là où l'église se rassemble, il y a un grand temple, un grand bâtiment,
mais ça reste encore la petite chapelle dans laquelle ils ont commencé.
Et donc, c'est très important de remarquer qu'en général, la croissance n'est pas explosive.
En général, c'est un travail d'honorer beaucoup, être fidèle dans le peu, avec excellence dans les petits commencements
et démontrer de manière sacrificielle comment nous voulons consacrer nos vies afin d'améliorer chaque fois plus et de maximiser chaque fois plus.
De ne jamais tomber dans cette pression culturelle qu'on a dans nos jours, de faire les minimums nécessaires.
De vouloir trop protéger notre bien-être personnel ou nos conforts personnels.
Donc, c'est la mission la plus significative qu'on peut faire.
Et donc, notre objectif, c'est de faire avancer chaque fois plus et de maximiser chaque fois plus.
Donc, l'excellence et la prédisposition passive, c'est à nouveau, je reviens à cette idée de l'ange qui est là.
Il est tout simplement là.
Si jamais on a besoin, tant mieux.
Donc là, par exemple, dans les conférences, on planifie certaines choses qui peuvent changer complètement.
Et il y a beaucoup de personnes qui sont assignées à faire certaines tâches qui, à la fin des comptes, ne sont même pas utilisées.
Et nous ne devrons pas être frustrés car l'office est plus important que l'exercice quelque part.
Et le sentiment des privilèges d'être officiellement serviteur à disposition est plus important que de me sentir utilisé.
Car rien qu'être à disposition, c'est déjà super.
C'est bon ?
Donc là, c'est important car il faut savoir que même de manière passive, on doit être « dependable ».
Comment on dit ça en français ?
« Dependable ».
Oui, disposer, mais avec fiabilité.
On peut faire totale confiance.
Voilà, que cette personne sera toujours à disposition.
Que sa réponse sera toujours oui.
Quand un service est évoqué.
Prompt.
Ce n'est pas les types de personnes qui, on sait parfois qu'elle est la meilleure ou la plus capable à faire certaines choses.
Mais on pense qu'on est dans l'obligation de planifier la chose avec un mois en avance pour qu'elle puisse servir à quelque chose.
C'est par office et par vocation quelqu'un qui est à disposition.
À disposition au service.
Tant mieux si on peut planifier.
La règle générale, c'est de nous planifier.
Ça fait partie de l'excellence aussi.
Par contre, il y a à plusieurs reprises des besoins et des opportunités, même pas que des besoins, qui peuvent apparaître pour maximiser les services, qui peuvent nous prendre par surprise.
Et donc constance, fiabilité, sens des commissions.
Donc voilà, c'est ce sens des joies, crainte et rénonce.
Qui est essentiellement très caractéristique déjà du terme diaconal.
C'est esclave vraiment littéralement.
Et donc c'est déjà une rénonce totale pour un service.
C'est l'exemple du Christ.
Ok.
Et donc c'est un service d'esclaves mais avec joie, crainte et sens des significations.
Donc l'essence des commissions, il revient à cette notion, l'église des dieux.
Et tout cela, ce sont des qualifications fonctionnelles.
Quand on voit ces personnes à service, c'est ça qu'on identifie.
Un cœur, service sale et une preuve pratique de cette prédisposition à servir.
Intentionnalité.
Et là, l'intentionnalité, c'est de revenir aux trois buts essentiels qu'on a considérés.
L'unité de l'église.
Et donc si jamais on est demandé par les membres de l'église ou par les anciens
à nous occuper de certaines tâches qui sont triviales par rapport à la promotion de l'évangile,
on peut dire clairement, j'étais convoqué par Christ,
non pour dépenser mon temps avec un tel type de tâches.
J'étais convoqué par Christ pour pouvoir.
Peux-tu me montrer comment ces services peuvent faire promouvoir l'évangile,
faire promouvoir la parole, la prière,
comment ça peut jouer pour l'unité de l'église.
Ok ?
Et donc, est-ce que vous avez des questions avant qu'on avance ?
On peut en poser nous des questions ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Tu viens d'insister pas mal sur la prédisposition au service,
même quand c'est sur le moment, etc.
Mais comment on peut équilibrer ça avec les fois où c'est aussi pertinent de dire non ?
Parce qu'être beaucoup sollicité, dire oui tout le temps,
ça peut aussi amener à même pécher sous d'autres aspects.
Oui.
Et dans d'autres responsabilités qu'on a,
donc comment équilibrer ça ?
Oui, je pense qu'il n'y a pas une formule définie pour contempler cet équilibre.
Mais je pense que par la manière dont on réagit
et la fréquence dont on essaye de se positionner,
on peut commencer à discerner petit à petit
si c'est une personne peut-être parfois très attachée
à un confort organisationnel
ou si c'est une personne qui parfois dira non
en ayant démontré à plusieurs reprises qu'elle a dit à plusieurs reprises oui.
Donc là, mon exemple personnel pour ce type de situation,
c'est comme j'ai déjà mentionné dans la prédication,
je sais de l'importance pour mes enfants de dormir bien
pour la routine scolaire.
Mais de temps en temps, pendant les dévotions avant de dormir,
elles posent des questions qui sont très importantes.
Et donc, comme je vois une opportunité tangible
de maximiser leur évangélisation,
je n'y pense pas deux fois.
Je pense que ça va être mieux pour elles
de mieux comprendre l'évangile
et souffrir physiquement les lendemains
que l'opposé.
Et donc, dans les quotidiens, dans la vie de tous les jours,
et dans les Nouveaux Testaments, bien sûr,
les paramètres qu'on a des services,
on va voir un Jésus qui s'éloigne des disciples
pour pouvoir se reposer et prier.
Et il rentre dans la barque pour s'éloigner de la multitude,
pour avoir un moment un peu plus réservé,
mais il voit que les peuples courent par les bords de la mer
et il devient très compatissant.
Ce sont des brébis qui n'ont pas de berger.
Et donc, quand on voit la séquence des journées du Christ
tellement fatigué en enseignant la parole,
il ne peut pas résister à un besoin concret
pour maximiser l'évangile.
Donc, en général, la règle des bases,
c'est que nous devons être bien ordonnés dans notre vie de famille,
de prioriser notre vie de famille.
Mais si nos agendas ne sont pas,
à long terme,
défiés et confirmés par des sacrifices récourants,
on doit se poser la question,
si on n'est pas en train de chérir trop
une anzelle envers mon fonctionnement peut-être familial
ou professionnel,
plus qu'est la promotion du Rheum.
Donc, il n'y a pas une formule définie pour évaluer ces choses,
mais pour faire très court,
je dois savoir quand est-ce que je dois dire non,
mais je ne peux pas,
après, voilà,
quelques années des ministères,
réviser les noms que j'ai dits
et ne pas trouver plusieurs oui aussi
en termes de sacrifice.
Donc, par exemple,
je pense que nous, on a un défi annuel
pour toute l'Église
où je pense que tout ce qui s'engage
pour la promotion de la conférence
sont en train de sacrifier beaucoup de leur temps.
beaucoup de leur temps de famille,
beaucoup de leur temps de travail professionnel,
et ça, c'est un exemple concret.
La seule différence, c'est que pour ça,
nous pouvons nous planifier beaucoup en avance.
On sait dans quel mois,
dès l'année,
tous les années, on va faire ça.
Mais parfois,
ce sont des défis qui ne vont pas être pour nous.
Pour nous, en tant qu'anciens,
des fois, voilà,
je suis fatigué,
je veux rentrer à la maison,
mais un problème grave est apparu
et une personne à 22 heures
après l'étude biblique du vendredi
nous partage cette situation.
Donc, je sais que c'est important
de rentrer à la maison,
mais il y a des choses pour lesquelles
on ne peut pas dire non.
En même temps,
il y a beaucoup de personnes
qui, on sait,
qui veulent beaucoup notre temps,
mais pas pour des causes très importantes.
Et pour eux,
on doit clairement savoir du non.
c'est important.
Et donc,
c'est la même chose
pour les diacres.
Il faut qu'ils se planifient
pour séparer des heures
hebdomadaires
pour les services planifiés
qui soient réalistes
envers les demandes familiales
et professionnelles qu'ils ont
sans déshonorer ces choses,
servir.
Mais des fois,
ils peuvent être sollicités
à donner un peu plus
pour quelque chose de ponctuel,
pour quelque chose de surpris,
non, etc.
Ça répond à la question ?
Oui.
Ok.
Cette prochaine section,
je ne vais pas prendre beaucoup de temps
car on a déjà fait un exercice
même avec l'Église sur ça.
Est-ce que les femmes
peuvent être diacres ?
Donc,
dans l'histoire de l'Église,
on a fait un travail
vraiment très méticuleux,
on dit ça en français ?
Avec l'équipe pastorale.
Et on a constaté
que dans l'histoire de l'Église,
il y a eu une majorité
des positions
pour les diaconats féminins.
Même si quelques nuances
par rapport à ça
ont toujours lieu
dans les sens où,
pour certains,
c'était compris dans la notion,
par exemple,
des veuves,
pour certains,
c'était compris
avec une compréhension particulière
de leur aspect féminin.
Dans les systèmes catholiques,
c'est plutôt les sœurs,
comme on dit,
qui auront un peu
cette emphase majeure
avec les notions
des diaconesses aussi.
et de manière très intéressante,
on voit
qu'il y a eu
plus récemment
avec les mouvements féministes,
il y a eu aussi
une réaction plus moderne,
un peu parfois,
peut-être exagérée,
dans la direction opposée.
C'est comme si,
dans nos jours,
on avait possiblement
une majorité d'Églises
qui seraient plutôt
contre la notion
des diaconesses,
mais qui vont garder,
voilà,
soit une assistance diaconale.
En tout cas,
les positions majoritaires
ont toujours été
soit épouse des diacres,
soit diaconesses.
Et au milieu
de ces positions,
il y a la notion
des assistantes diaconales.
Et pour certains,
et c'est minoritaire,
cette classe des femmes
évoquées à 1er Timothée III,
comme il y a aussi
la classe des veuves,
qui sont consacrées
totalement au ministère,
les veuves qui se servent
à l'Église
sont considérées
comme cette classe
possiblement abordée
en 1er Timothée III.
Donc,
quelle est notre position
à nous ?
Donc,
les ministères plus proches
qui exercent
une influence sur nos vies
sont divisés.
Donc,
Ligonier,
par exemple,
pas Ligonier,
mais l'Église
des Borghpassons,
pour lui,
ce n'est pas diaconess.
Par contre,
pour Heartcry,
MacArthur
et d'autres ministères,
ils sont pour diaconess.
C'est juste pour démontrer
comment ces choses
peuvent être divisées
dans la compréhension.
Et dans notre équipe pastorale,
on est arrivé à la position
qui serait possiblement
la plus profitable
pour notre Église,
qui est de considérer
la classe d'assistante diaconale.
Quelle est la préoccupation ici ?
On reconnaît comme étant
une classe officielle.
OK ?
Mais pour éviter
de les considérer
comme les assistantes directes
d'un diacre spécifique,
qu'il y ait toujours la dépendance
que les ministères
des diaconesse,
entre guillemets,
soient connectés
au ministère des diacres hommes,
qu'on sache reconnaître
qu'elles sont là
pour aider officiellement
les ministères diaconales
plutôt que diacres eux-mêmes.
C'est clair la distinction ?
Donc nous, on va faire
ces choix
qui nous jugeons être cohérents
avec les passages bibliques.
Et nous allons expliquer
comment ces choses
vont prendre forme plus tard.
Mais en tout cas,
la complémentarité créationnelle,
elle atteste
de la légitimité
que l'aide des femmes
soit utilisée,
car même dans les mariages,
on voit les deux
ont la même dignité
mais des rôles
de service différents,
l'homme qui va conduire
et la femme qui est son aide.
Et cette expression aide,
elle est importante
car le Nouveau Testament,
diacre,
a aussi cette signification.
Et donc,
l'assistance féminine
dans la Bible
est présente partout.
Quand on voit
l'Ancien Testament
et le Nouveau Testament,
on a plein d'exemples
pardon,
des femmes
qui ont toujours servi
comme assistantes
au ministère,
soit des prophètes,
soit vraiment
du peuple des dieux,
des leaders du peuple des dieux
partout.
Donc,
on a juste
Rebecca
qui donne à boire
au serviteur d'Abraham,
on a Myriam,
la sœur de Moïse
qui est aidée aussi.
Il y a Déborah
qui est très importante
comme repère
car elle est très mauvaise
utilisée.
Mais c'est intéressant,
Déborah,
elle n'était pas
un juge d'office,
elle est dans les livres
des juges,
mais elle était
une prophétesse
qui travaillait
de manière très distincte
des prophètes
de l'Ancien Testament.
Elle travaillait
sous l'arbre,
sur les jardins
de sa maison,
de manière très féminine
encore.
Et elle était
un exemple
des jugements
sur Israël
à cause de la lâcheté
de cette génération
des leaders.
Mais elle servait
pour aider Israël
de manière très féminine
même si elle a dû
exercer une fonction masculine
à cause
du manque
de courage
et d'intégrité
des barraques.
On a Jaël
qui va accueillir
Cicéra
dans sa tente
pour délivrer Israël.
On a Naomi
et Ruth,
on a Abigail,
on a la tsunami
qui a beaucoup aidé
les ministères d'Élysée.
On a Rahab
qui a caché
les espions
d'Israël.
On a Ster
qui a intercédé
de manière très féminine
aussi et humble
pour les biens d'Israël.
Donc on a
dans l'Ancien Testament
plein de femmes
qui ont beaucoup aidé
de manière très efficace
pour la prospérité
du peuple des dieux.
Quand on arrive
au Nouveau Testament,
on a la belle mère
de Pierre
qui avait l'habitude
d'héberger
Jésus et les disciples.
On a Marie
de Bethany
qui était la sœur
de Marthe
et Marthe elle-même
aussi qui aidait
aussi Christ
de manière très pratique.
On a les femmes
qui suivaient
Jésus en Galilée.
Donc à nouveau,
Marie-Madeleine,
Jeanne,
Suzanne,
qui sont évoquées
en Luc 8
comme celles
qui étaient là
pour assister
de leurs biens.
Et plusieurs autres.
La Bible va mentionner
qu'il y avait encore
plusieurs autres.
On a Marie-Madeleine,
Marie-mère de Jacques
et Salomé
qui apportaient
les aromates
pour vendre
les corps du Christ
et qui étaient toujours
en train de suivre
son ministère.
Et quand on va aussi
les apôtres,
l'apôtre Paul surtout,
il donne des grandes listes
des femmes
qui l'ont aidée.
On peut penser
à Lydie,
cette marchande des pourpres
qui était la première
convertie en Europe
qui ouvrait sa maison
aux apôtres.
On peut penser à Priscille
qui aidait aussi
le ministère
de l'évangélisation
de son mari Aquilas
et la formation
des disciples.
Feb,
on voit aussi
qui est déclaré
les plus probablement
comme une diaconess
d'office
et pas informellement
tout simplement
une servante.
On a Évody
et Saint-Ish.
qui s'appelle
Bonne Route,
Saint-Ish
qui s'appelle
Bienveillance,
et on a
Chloé
qui va rapporter
à Paul
par rapport
à la division
dans cette église.
Il y a
à Coranthe
donc il y a
Nipha
qui héberge
une église
dans sa maison.
Il y en a
beaucoup d'autres
qui sont mentionnés
dans les Nouveaux Testaments
particulièrement liés
au ministère
de l'apôtre Paul.
Et donc
on voit partout
dans la pratique
des services
très diaconales
qui sont exercés
par des femmes
qui sont distinctes
dans la parole
des dieux.
Et donc
il y a cette question
que je vous ai
déjà expliquée
notre position
d'assistance
diaconale
et à partir de là
on va vous présenter
plus tard
la notion
des coordinations
à cet égard.
Est-ce que vous avez
des questions
par rapport à ça ?
Oui ou non ?
Ça serait très incohérent
au niveau
car la Bible
elle est très
elle est très exigeante
envers la position
des anciens
surtout
mais de tous les chrétiens
par rapport
à leur conviction
personnelle.
Si je suis arrivé
en conclusion
en conviction
à partir des écritures
je suis obligé
à marcher
à la hauteur
de ce que j'ai reçu.
Et donc
les petites nuances
qu'on a trouvées
entre nous
entre l'équipe
pastorale
c'est réglé
après beaucoup
réflexion et prière
par cette solution.
Moi je suis plutôt
de l'avis
de la conviction
que diaconès
devrait être institué.
Mais ce n'était pas
forcément la position
de tous
et même si
cette inclinaison
était présente
dans les cœurs
de la majorité
ou de tous
la préoccupation
aussi
de la possibilité
de ne pas avoir
de diaconès
et des risques
d'être confondus
avec l'autorité
ou la position masculine
on a trouvé
que c'était légitime
aussi d'agir
de cette manière.
Mais moins que ça
je pense qu'on n'a pas
de conviction pour faire
et voilà pourquoi
notre choix
va dans cette direction.
Ça répond à ta question ?
Une autre question.
Dans acte 6
les précurseurs
sont donc tous
les hommes
et on leur impose
les mains
pour l'ordination
est-ce que
de même
les assistants
de diaconal
seraient ordonnés
avec imposition
des mains
et pourquoi ?
Voilà, ça c'est
une très bonne question
et donc
la difficulté
de cette question
d'un côté
c'est la notion
d'investiture
d'autorité
qui parfois
est nuancée
par ces choses
en même temps
c'est aussi
signification
d'investiture
des puissances
et reconnaissance
des séparations
ou actions
pour un service.
Comme la définition
du ministère
elle est
prédominamment
ministère des services
il n'y aurait pas
d'incohérence
pour la capacitation
des femmes
à servir.
Et un autre aspect
c'est que
l'aspect
informel
encore
des précurseurs
des diacres
ok
car il n'y a pas
les termes
l'office
et c'est unonyme
presque
entre les exégènes
les interprétateurs
de la Bible
qui est la notion
officielle
de cet appel
n'est qu'il se passer
à partir
des premières
Timothée 3
ok
et donc
dans ce sens là
si
l'imposition
des mains
a lieu
dans un contexte
informel
on ne pourrait pas
on pourrait
ne pas se soucier
si tant
d'exercer
une prière
d'imposition
pour la séparation
pour une charge
spécifique.
Ça dépend vraiment
de comment
nous voulons
communiquer
comment nous devons
expliquer les choses
car c'est clair
qu'il y a un poids
beaucoup plus lourd
lorsqu'on va faire
l'imposition
des mains
sur les anciens
car il y a
un rôle particulier
mais c'est particulièrement
la description
de leur rôle
qui porte les poids
aussi sur cette imposition
mais on voit
dans la Bible aussi
d'autres moments
où l'imposition
des mains
est faite
même si
ce n'est pas
un cadre
d'ordination
c'est plutôt
un cadre
des prières
tout simplement
et donc
voilà pourquoi
on se sentirait
en paix
pour prier
pour ces femmes
pour qu'elles soient
séparées
pour exercer
cette fonction
au sein de l'Église
c'est une très bonne question
et les anciens qui sont là
vous pouvez aussi réagir
si vous voulez
en fait
pour comprendre
qu'en termes
de services
des liens
ou des
des conquistants
diakonais
en fait
il n'y a aucune distinction
!
oui la distinction
c'est tout simplement
que les hommes
et les femmes
serviront
lorsqu'on considère
l'intégration
de leur service
en respectant
la distinction
de leur sexe
et chacun
servira
en conformité
avec sa sexualité
les femmes
serviront
de manière féminine
les hommes
serviront
de manière masculine
peu importe
quels soient les services
qu'ils soient en train d'exercer
et dans leur interaction
ok
il faut
que
tous les soins
et préoccupations
de la protection
de ces relations
en toute pureté
l'emphase mise
par l'apôtre Paul
est lieu
tout comme nous
les anciens
on n'a pas
d'entretien
seul avec une femme
et tout comme
si par exemple
on a des ministères
indépendants
où c'est que
les femmes
qui travaillent
elles peuvent réjouir
dans certains niveaux
d'indépendance
par rapport
aux autres diacres
sous la supervision
du ministère pastoral
par contre
si les hommes
et les femmes
servent ensemble
dans un ministère
diaconal
idéalement
donc effectivement
il faut que
les hommes
soient plutôt
en train de diriger
la coordination
de ces ministères
c'est clair
et éviter
toutes sortes
d'intimités
dangereuses
dans ces cadres là
c'est clair
donc ce qu'on doit éviter
c'est par exemple
je vais donner
un exemple
très pratique
Gloria
est en train
de gérer
l'organisation
de la nourriture
et du repas
pour
la conférence
sous la supervision
des anciens
mais si
quelques diacres
veulent venir
aider
ça serait un peu
compliqué
car quelqu'un
devrait prendre
la position
des dirigeants
des coordonnations
car ça serait
à l'inverse
des principes publics
des coordonnations
entre hommes et femmes
c'est clair
en même temps
rien n'empêche
les hommes
d'être cordial
et amener
la nourriture
à la table
ok
prendre les poids
lourds des choses
ouais
pour promouvoir
la paix
dans l'église
par exemple
il y a un conflit
si j'ai bien compris
le rôle du diac
c'est plutôt
de promouvoir ça
peut-être
que je n'ai pas bien
compris comment
mais si on peut
exhorter
on peut
parler
d'un moment
comme ça
ça reste
une répression
donc du coup
une femme
pourra faire ça
c'est ça
la question
si une femme
veut faire
un réproche
à un homme
au sein de la communauté
il faut
si jamais
elle l'est fait
à cause d'une urgence
ou d'un besoin
qu'elle l'est face
de la manière
la plus humble
la plus respectueuse
et la plus féminine
tout comme ma femme
elle a
la répréhension
ou la correction
l'influence
envers la correction
qu'elle va apporter
sur moi
n'a pas besoin
forcément de signifier
un exercice d'autorité
d'elle envers moi
c'est une aide
qui est en train
de me rendre
de me prêter
car j'ai besoin
d'être corrigé
et donc ça va dépendre
vraiment de la manière
dont elle va se communiquer
avec moi
c'est clair
c'est pas forcément
un exercice d'autorité
l'exhortation mutuelle
en même temps
si
par la sagesse chrétienne
elle perçoit
que si jamais
elle va appeler
l'attention d'un homme
ça peut sonner pour lui
comme en soumission
il vaut mieux
qu'elle partage ça
avec
les anciens
ou avec son épouse
ok
c'est clair
vous êtes d'accord
avec ça
les anciens
ok
oui
mais c'est pour ça
qu'on parle
dans ce sens
qu'acte 6
il faut le voir
comme
les précurseurs
ça veut dire
que c'était pas encore
le ministère
de diapes
qui était établi
en tant que tel
mais ça donnait déjà
une piste
parce qu'après
ce qui se passe
et quand nous lisons
la suite du nouveau test
à mon
nous voyons qu'il y a
des besoins
qui sont arrivés
et pour la protection
de l'église
ce sont des besoins
qui ne pourraient être
à aucun moment
que par les soeurs
un moment
lorsqu'il s'agit
de prendre soin
de
ce que l'on va conseiller
des veuves
peut avoir un peu plus
de temps
de prendre soin
de certaines soeurs
plus jeunes
parce que ça
c'est pas un rôle
que les diacres
sur la première phase
auraient pu faire
donc à un moment
ce sont des besoins
où la personne
justement
en faisant
en remplissant
ce rôle de service
va avoir
cet investissement
qui est un travail
diaconal
et donc voilà
pourquoi les besoins
de l'église aussi
avec beaucoup de sagesse
on a des besoins
spécifiques
ou par exemple
l'école du dimanche
comme ça
souvent ça va être
plutôt des soeurs
qui sont bourrières
qui n'aiment même pas
de faire
ce sont des soeurs
qui s'en occupent
et là au moment
c'était
voilà
mais là à chaque fois
ça va toujours être
sous la supervision
des anciens
donc elles sont même pas
en train d'exercer
nos tentatives
elles sont en train
d'aider les anciens
dans ce travail
toujours dans le travail
pour qu'on puisse
s'occuper de la parole
de la prière
et c'est toujours
en ce sens
que ça donne
merci Steph
très bonne contribution
juste comme complément
il faut remarquer
que le fait
d'avoir choisi
des hommes
montre aussi
la sagesse
dans cet épisode
pour régler un problème
entre les femmes
donc il y avait
beaucoup de divisions
déjà entre les femmes
donc c'était nécessaire
que ces hommes viennent
et qu'ils exercent
un peu plus d'autorité
pour régler
cette question
et c'était pas encore
une question
officielle
et juste pour revenir
à l'exemple
du ministère
d'enfants
à notre église
aujourd'hui
c'est pas
unonyme
dans les églises
que ce soit
que les femmes
donc la Bible
à nouveau
on n'a pas peur
de stéréotypes
et en général
les plus jeunes
sont les enfants
d'une manière générale
ce sont les femmes
qui occupent
plus de temps
avec eux
mais c'est très important
aussi d'envisager
comme vision
pour les ministères
d'enfants
que les hommes
participent aussi
à leur enseignement
mais si on n'a pas
une personne
qu'on identifie
comme suffisamment
expérimentée
qui soit un modèle
des familles
des pères
etc.
qui a l'appel
pour la supervision
du ministère
d'enfants
encore
on sait reconnaître
qu'on ne va pas
mettre une personne
qui ne va pas
qualifier
pour ça
spécifiquement
et donc pour l'instant
les ministères
des enfants
restent
sur une mobilisation
des femmes
mais par exemple
chez MacArthur
et même chez Ligonir
ce sont les hommes
aussi qui donnent
les cours
pour les enfants
et qui dirigent
les ministères
d'enseignement
d'enfants
et c'est important
car c'est la reproduction
de ce qui doit se passer
aussi à la maison
ce sont les hommes
qui ont la première
responsabilité
et les femmes
qui peuvent passer
plus d'étant
peut-être faire
avec une fréquence
même plus grande
mais la présence
des hommes
elle est très importante
aussi dans ces ministères
ça répond à vos questions
je pense qu'il faut
qu'on prie pour ça
mais il ne faut pas
qu'on soit précipité
il ne faut pas
voilà
il faut qu'on trouve
une personne
suffisamment expériente
et qu'il soit appelé
pour ça
en tout cas
ce qu'il faut faire
c'est
et c'est ça
quelque chose
qu'on essaie
de régler aussi
c'est
de mieux articuler
peut-être même
avec l'aide
des certains
diacres
ou assistantes
des diacres
de mieux articuler
même la supervision
des ministères
de manière générale
ça passe par
la consécration
à temps plan
des anciens
pour qu'on soit
plus actif
et proactif
dans la supervision
des ministères
mais ça passe aussi
par une meilleure
assistance
en termes
des pratiques
d'organisation
et de communication
donc
Ligonier
par exemple
Chris Larson
il fonctionne
comme un CEO
mais
dans mes interactions
avec eux
c'était très intéressant
de remarquer
que tout ce qui est
logistique
tout ce qui est pratique
tout ce qui va toucher
à l'excellence
et leur service
sera traité
avec toute liberté
par Crise de la Somme
lui-même
en même temps
à chaque fois
que je pose
des questions théologiques
thème pour la conférence
etc
il me redirige
envers
Burke Parsons
ce qui montre clairement
qu'en réel
même s'il est
le CEO
des Ligonier
il est un diacre
au sein des Ligonier
et les pasteurs
de Ligonier
quelque part
restent
Boff Passon
et c'est
respect
la manière
dont il va s'effreiner
de dire des choses
qu'il pourrait dire
mais ça démontre
véritablement
un sens
des commissions
diaconales
vraiment très remarquable
où il a toutes les réponses
mais il préfère
les rediriger
envers les anciens
oui
bien sûr
je donne un exemple
par exemple
le groupe de ménage
actuellement
il n'y a pas de responsable
vraiment
moi j'ai pris la responsabilité
parce qu'il faut faire des familles
mais est-ce que du coup
quand il y a des hommes
dans un groupe de ménage
et que ben
ils demandent souvent conseils
à lui
pour interagir
est-ce que
est-ce que c'est judicieux
de proposer à des hommes
s'il y a des hommes dans l'équipe
l'idéal c'est qu'eux ils prennent la charge des responsabilités
d'accord
donc
comme toutes les choses sont un peu informelles encore dans cette organisation
c'est important pour nous de mettre les choses en ordre
ministère des femmes etc
et idéalement il n'y a aucun organisme qui n'ait pas des têtes
et donc c'est pas bien que les ministères fonctionnent un peu
tout simplement au bénévolat comme ça
donc l'objectif c'est de traverser tous les ministères actifs
et d'identifier au sein de ces ministères des binômes
pas avec des responsabilités égales mais impréminents
qui puissent compter avec un autre qui soit de son côté avec les poids des responsabilités
et eux ils seront donc une personne principale et quelqu'un comme assistant
dans la responsabilité
donc c'est un peu comme un peu comme un peu comme un peu comme un peu
assistant dans la responsabilité ok donc tous les ministères au sein de l'église
et s'il ya la présence d'un homme
que l'homme soit celui qui occupe la position des responsabilités
c'est clair
c'est dans cette direction qu'on veut aller
ok pour organiser l'église
on peut avancer
ok il faut que j'avance un peu plus vite là
ok donc là on arrive à ce qu'on appelle on va dire les plus grandes motivations pour les diakona
donc on a quelques passages bibliques
attendez
et à nouveau en fait les images ont été choisies de manière très intentionnelle
tout comme les services des diakona doit être toujours très intentionnelle
personnellement
personnellement donc c'est une c'est une peinture
si je ne me trompe pas elle est au louvre
mais il faut que je vérifie après
par contre j'étais intentionnel aussi pour couper la représentation
de l'église
et donc on a quelques passages bibliques
et à nouveau en fait les images ont été choisies de manière très intentionnelle
tout comme les services des diakona doit être toujours très intentionnelle
personnellement donc c'est une c'est une peinture
si je ne me trompe pas elle est au louvre mais il faut que je vérifie après
par contre j'étais intentionnel aussi pour couper la représentation du christ et des dieux les pères
car c'est un péché selon la bible
donc je vais laisser quand même un ange là
mais c'est étienne lapidé diacre qui a la vision du christ lui-même
ce qui parle énormément à propos de la motivation des diacres
c'est un service qu'on fait au perdu pour l'avancement de l'église
c'est un service qu'on fait pour aider les anciens
c'est un service qu'on fait pour promouvoir l'église
mais c'est un service qu'on fait comme si on était en train de faire pour christ seul
si je suis en train de nettoyer les toilettes de l'église
je les fais car je sais que mon seigneur me voit
j'ai fait pour lui je les fais avec excellence
les puritans qui étaient persécutés étaient reconnus car ils faisaient les
polir
il polissait les chaises même là où personne ne voyait
et donc il faut qu'on fasse pour christ il faut qu'on fasse indépendamment de la manière dont les autres sont en train de faire
il faut qu'on fasse sans attendre la reconnaissance sans attendre même un merci ou un bonjour
il faut qu'on les fasse sachant que les seigneurs chéris et comptabilise tous les services qu'on fait pour la gloire de son nom
et donc la plus grande ou les plus grandes motivations pour les diacres c'est de servir à christ
mieux connaître christ à la mesure où on sert car il est les repères suprêmes des services donc on connaît de plus en plus son caractère son amour quand on sert comme lui
et c'est tout simplement des refléter à christ dans la manière dont tu nous a servi
et donc on dit c'est de refléter les diacres suprêmes
car quand on va vers la bible
voici la première récompense évoquée dans les contextes de primaire timothée 3
car ceux qui remplissent convenablement leur ministère s'acquiert un rang honorable et une grande assurance dans la foi en jésus christ
et donc je me demande paul et nous connaissons c'est très touchant pour moi mais nous connaissons l'histoire de paul
qui était présent ici d'ailleurs il est ici dans la peinture mais
et il a participé à l'assassinat d'étienne
et il a contemplé quelqu'un qui a acquis un rang honorable je pense qu'il n'y a pas un passage biblique
qui met une personne dans un rang plus honorable que celui d'étienne
il n'y a aucun passage d'écriture qui nous montre les christ ressuscités glorifiés qui s'élèvent de son trône pour contempler la mort d'étienne
pour l'encourager au moment il est en train de rendre les principales services
de renoncer littéralement sa vie pour promouvoir la vie des autres
et je ne peux pas m'empêcher d'imaginer que l'apôtre paul lorsqu'il pense à ceux qui exercent bien les rôles des diacres acquiert un rang honorable
un rang honorable il devrait l'avoir dans la foi
nous devrions les chérir énormément l'église devrait apprendre à les chérir
mais même si l'église n'arrive pas à chérir comme il faut
il faut qu'on sache qu'il est christ il est en train de chérir
il se met debout pour voir diacre et tienne lapidé
en essayant de promouvoir la réconciliation son serment parle sur la réconciliation entre ceux qui ont assassiné les christ qui étaient responsables de la mort du christ en donnant encore une opportunité pour la réconciliation avec christ
et donc il n'attend aucun merci il attend des pierres mais sa vision va au delà des pierres qui
il reçoit sur sa tête il est en train de contempler christ seul
il est en train de servir christ seul et il est en train de servir comme christ
car même dans sa mort il va reproduire la phrase qui christ a dit à la croix
pardon leur ils savent pas ce qu'ils font
et donc ici nous vont nous voyons nous avons un repère incroyable des diacres tout simplement
qui devrait nous enseigner à avoir pour motivation suprême
les rangs honorables dans la foi
d'autres personnes qui ont eu ces dons honorables dans la foi on peut penser
en mathieu 26 le cas des marines de bethany où elle va gaspiller entre guillemets les trésors de sa famille
et sera réprochée par judas mais jésus qui sera sa défense et qui la met dans une position très honorable car par la manière dont elle a méprisé l'argent
pour servir à christ comme une esclave
elle acquiert un rang très honorable elle démontre la force de sa foi
la force de sa foi qui méprise l'argent
lorsqu'elle saisit une opportunité pour faire un bien à la cause du royaume des dieux
faire les moindres biens à christ
et c'est incroyable de voir
elle a fait une bonne action à mon égard
elle m'a béni littéralement
on ne peut pas imaginer comment on pourrait bénir
les dieux qui est infiniment bienheureux
mais jésus considère que nous les bénissons
elle a fait une bonne action à mon égard
car vous avez toujours des pauvres avec vous
mais vous ne m'avez pas toujours
en répandant ses parfums sur mon corps
elle a fait pour ma sépulture
je vous l'ai dit en vérité
par toute cette bonne nouvelle s'est répréché
dans le monde entier on racontera aussi en mémoire de cette femme
ce qu'elle a fait
un rang honorable dans la foi
acquis par un service d'esclaves
laver les pieds du christ avec son parfum
laver sa tête avec son parfum
et embaumer les christs
par anticipation envers la mort
envers sa crucifixion
ce qui démontre véritablement sa foi
son attachement à l'évangile
et des christs à la croix
et donc ici nous avons cet exemple
du père qui dit voici mon fils bien aimé
en qui j'ai mis toute ma affection
après la tentation au désert
et les anges qui viennent servir jésus après la tentation
donc il faut considérer les rangs honorables
on est en train de servir comme les anges
en faisant des services très simples
mais qui sont en train d'aider la promotion du rame de Dieu
et donc etienne aussi
si on revient à ces passages
on voit comment son visage
paru comme celui d'un ange
la manière dont il va les yeux vers la gloire de Dieu
et la manière dont il mort en disant
et puis le Seigneur n'a l'ampute pas ses péchés
et après ses paroles il s'en donne
et donc même avec sa mort
Etienne va servir comme diacre à la croissance de l'église
la croissance explosive de l'église a lieu après la mort d'Etienne
et donc quelles sont les récompenses et motivations des diacres ?
Dans certains cas ça sera la rémunération
donc si jamais une église a tellement besoin
qu'une fonction particulière soit exercée
et que cette fonction puisse exiger une consécration à temps plan
Paul Hacher lui-même une fois il a dit
c'était l'une des considérations qu'on avait
quand j'ai proposé que Gabriel puisse venir nous joindre
pour prendre soin de la partie des médias
j'ai demandé est-ce que vous avez la vision pour investir
dans un diacre à temps plan ?
Et Paul Hacher a dit vite
je crois que même la méthode missionnaire
pour l'implantation des églises
devrait commencer à considérer un pasteur
ou même peut-être deux pasteurs et un diacre à temps plan
pour aider dans toutes les choses pratiques, administratives
pour l'église
et donc il y aura cette possibilité
mais c'est clair que la règle biblique
va pas dans cette direction
ça c'est plutôt exceptionnel
des diacres à temps plan
on peut comprendre comment
ça peut être possible et légitime
et parfois il faut savoir et connaître
que dans la Bible il y a explicitement
un nombre énorme de motivations
pour la rémunération des pasteurs à temps plan
et on a un silence par rapport à la rémunération d'anciens
par contre
des diacres pardon
des diacres merci
mais c'est de plus en plus commun dans certaines églises dans nos jours
où certains ministères peuvent vraiment maximiser les ministères de l'église par leur service
donc par exemple il y a souvent des équipes de médias qui sont embauchées à temps plan
il y a des secrétaires qui sont embauchés à temps plan
et nous ne pouvons pas nous empêcher d'envisager cette structure pour notre église
surtout à la mesure où l'église grandit aussi
mais bien sûr que cela n'est pas du tout la motivation des diacres
au moins c'est pas la motivation primaire
c'est d'acquérir un renorable comme on vient de voir pour Etienne
pour Marie de Bethany
c'est surtout cette grande assurance dans la foi
et ça c'est très intéressant
car le plus on s'oblige à accomplir nos tâches
le plus on expérimente les privilèges
de contempler les œuvres des dieux à travers nos vies
de voir que l'église est en train de grandir
sachant qu'on a participé à cette croissance
à ces saluts des âmes
à ces baptêmes
avec l'aide active qu'on a employée
pour organiser la salle
pour nettoyer la salle
pour préparer la nourriture
pour travailler à l'accueil
peu importe
visible ou invisible
la réalité c'est que de plus en plus
je suis dans les lignes des fronts
pour contempler les dieux qui continuent d'opérer des miracles
et donc le plus on se consacre à notre tâche
le plus on grandit dans la foi
et donc on passe d'Étienne à Philippe
on voit comment à la mesure où il accomplissait son appel
il croissait en foi
et c'est la même chose pour nous
parfois d'assumer l'appel
est la meilleure manière de nous consacrer davantage à l'appel
et la meilleure manière d'être encore plus performant dans l'appel
et grandir dans la foi
s'habituer avec un Dieu qui fait encore des miracles
qui opère avec des puissances encore
et sommes-nous les diacres et les anciens
on travaille ensemble qui verront le plus souvent
donc c'est ça de grandir dans la foi et dans l'assurance
cette assurance dans la foi passe par cette audace avec laquelle Étienne prêche à l'évangile
et les privilèges que nous allons avoir
si nous libérons les anciens pour se consacrer à temps plein pour les ministères
sans s'occuper de ce travail
on verra de plus en plus des hommes consacrés à la prière et à la parole
et ils vont grandir aussi dans la proclamation de la foi
et nous serons sous leur impact aussi
et donc c'est l'échelon proposé par ces services
et c'est trois qui sont les plus importantes motivations
c'est servir à Christ
et en servissant à Christ et à Christ seul comme je vous ai dit
je les privilèges, ok ?
un Christ qui nous a dit si je donne un verre d'eau
c'est comme si j'ai donné à lui-même
vous êtes avec moi ?
si on fait les services les plus simples
les plus servissales à la personne la plus simple de la communauté
la personne la plus anonyme de la communauté
la personne la plus ou la moins importante dans la société
nous sommes en train de faire à la dignité des Christ lui-même
il prend comme si c'était pour lui
et c'est pour ça qu'on devrait avoir cette motivation
mais en servant à Christ nous apprenons plus sur Christ nous contemplons plus à Christ
nous comprenons mieux les Christ
et à partir de là on devient petit Christ pour les personnes
dans ses titres que Christ lui-même a reçu en tant que diacre suprême
donc il était plus qu'un diacre bien sûr
mais il était aussi un diacre
et la Bible l'appelle notamment par cette condescendance servissale du Dieu roi
qui s'est fait esclave à notre place
donc là c'est ces passages que nous trouvons devant nous
les récompenses et motivations des diacres
les rend
pardon
voilà ces passages là
qui nous dit
je passerai directement au chapitre 4
au verset 4
que chacun de vous
au lieu de considérer ses propres intérêts
considère aussi ceux des autres
c'est ça à l'essence ce qui est un diacre
ça passe même par une commande pizza
et qui prendra les morceaux les plus petits
ça passe par là
ça passe par
on va décider où on va commander la nourriture
on devrait avoir une dispute pour voir
qui cèdera à la proposition de qui
c'est de ne pas chercher que notre volonté soit faite
c'est que la volonté de Dieu soit faite
la volonté de Dieu communiquer à la pluralité d'anciens
et les préférences de l'autre viennent avant la mienne
et donc
qui chacun de vous au lieu de considérer ses propres intérêts
considère aussi ceux des autres
ayant voulu les sentiments qui étaient en Jésus Christ
lesquels existaient en forme de Dieu
n'a point regardé comme une proie arrachée d'être égal avec Dieu
mais
s'est dépouillé lui-même
en prenant une forme de serviteur
en dévenant semblable aux hommes
et en ayant paru comme un simple homme
il s'est humilié lui-même
s'est rendant obéissant
jusqu'à la mort
même jusqu'à la mort des croix
c'est pourquoi aussi
Dieu l'a souverainement élevé
et lui a donné les noms qui est au-dessus de tous noms
afin que le nom de Jésus
tous les genoux fléchissent dans les cieux
sur la terre et sur la terre
et que tout l'un confesse que Jésus Christ est Seigneur
à la gloire des dieux les pères
et donc on va de manière très claire ici
en prenant forme des diacres
dans l'original
un diacre qui démontre une prédisposition à être traité comme un esclave
jusqu'à la mort des croix
ok
donc c'est
c'est la plus grande condescendance volontaire
miséricorde c'est de nous rebaisser à l'état de misère de l'autre
afin de les faire remonter
et c'est ce que Christ a fait
en étant un diacre
il a acquis
les noms qui sont au-dessus de tout autre nom
car nous sommes devant l'expression maximale des diacres
la diminution volontaire
la renonce la plus élevée
ou la plus profonde
nous voyons aussi
comment Christ va acquérir cette position
par son nomination des positions suprêmes
un rang honorable dans la foi
les rangs les plus honorables dans la foi
c'est ici la motivation suprême des diacres
des questions avant petite pause café
non
dans un certain sens nous sommes tous des diacres
ça c'est correct
on a évoqué cette question au départ
car nous sommes tous appelés à servir les uns aux autres
donc là en Galates on est en train de voir l'empressement d'épaule
pour qu'on puisse manifester et être rempli du Saint-Esprit
en nous rendant serviteurs les uns des autres
donc de manière informelle oui nous sommes tous des diacres
par contre
le Seigneur Jésus a institué et a appelé à qualifier
une classe particulière des personnes au sein de l'église
pour devenir des officiers
et c'est important d'avoir cette suture
l'église elle est une ambassade formelle du roi des dieux
et donc nous ne pouvons pas tout diluer
mais c'est important d'avoir cette suture minimale dans l'église
deux ministères seulement officiels
anciens et diacres
et c'est important pour les biens de toute la communauté
d'avoir des repères officiels
de pouvoir apprendre par leur modèle
et savoir qu'ils ont reçu de la part des dieux et de cette église
la commission d'être un modèle de service pour nous tous
donc ça a un rôle didatique énorme pour la communauté aussi
Bon je vais juste avancer un point
honorer les diacs suprêmes avant la pause désolé
c'est juste qu'on doit avancer
vous m'appelez maître seigneur et vous dites bien car je les suis
si donc je vous ai lavé les pieds moi le seigneur et maître
vous devez aussi laver les pieds les uns des autres
car je vous ai donné un exemple
afin que vous fassiez comme je vous ai fait
en vérité en vérité je vous l'ai dit
les serviteurs n'est pas plus grand que son seigneur
ni l'apôtre plus grand que celui qui l'a envoyé
si vous savez ces choses vous êtes heureux pourvu que vous les pratiquiez
et donc là c'est de nous rappeler que nous devons non seulement
être motivés par les diacs suprêmes mais qu'on doit honorer les Christ en tant que diacres suprêmes
honorer dans le sens où nous allons nous rapporter à lui en tant que seigneur envers notre commission
mais aussi savoir qu'il lui-même a laissé les paramètres par lesquels on doit exercer ses rangs
donc je dois avoir une disponibilité angélique impressée et pure
donc on revient à des choses que j'ai déjà mis en phase
on doit chercher à reproduire une excellence des services célestes
par les modèles et par les plaisirs que je prends au service du Christ
les sens qui les anges ont malheureusement on n'a pas accès au Christ glorifié
avec la même vision et la même proximité littérale des anges
mais c'est clair que si on était plus conscient que cette distance n'existait pas forcément
spirituellement on serait beaucoup plus avec un sens des pédistes de savoir que nous sommes
une classe officielle des serviteurs du Christ le Seigneur ok
et donc je devrais servir avec toute cette excellence
à service ou au service d'un seul j'ai déjà mis cette emphase aussi
et je dois être des représentants bien présents
et là dans ce sens là pour rejoindre l'emphase des lindas nous sommes tous les diacres
et ça c'est intéressant car ici l'emphase c'est pour avoir la conscience que les diacres
ils sont les Christ lui-même les plus accessibles en termes de service aux personnes qui sont proches d'eux
c'est Christ qui est à leur service à travers ses serviteurs officiels
et donc l'anonymat qui glorifie c'est à dire qu'il est glorifié c'est à dire cette déclaration des Jean-Baptiste qu'ils croissent et que j'ai diminué
c'est l'objectif aussi des diacres pour honorer les diacres suprêmes
et donc la conclusion du livre se porte sur la sur cette révélation d'acte 6 comment la parole de Dieu se répand de plus en plus
car les anciens ont pu être libérés à cause du service des diacres donc les diacres doivent voir leur empreinte sur chaque serment prêché
donc comment l'engagement des diacres permet par exemple aux pasteurs des plus étudiés
donc de manière très pratique je me rappelle au début moi je m'occupais d'amener les poupitres et parfois c'est encore le cas
l'écran, les projecteurs, la caméra, la lumière je devrais prendre du temps pour tout installer pour tout faire etc
et aujourd'hui grâce à Dieu tout ce temps là peut être consacré à des choses plus pertinentes liées à mon ministère
et il faut que ça soit de plus en plus comme ça
il faut que ça soit de plus en plus comme ça
et donc ces empreintes sur l'unité de la communauté des pouvoirs
voilà de pouvoir tout simplement participer à quelques nuances à quelques préoccupations à quelques sensibilités
et aider aussi à la réconciliation et après un moment donné voir de quelle manière j'ai travaillé pour l'unité de cette communauté
ces empreintes sur l'excellence des ministères voilà comment on reflète la gloire de Dieu
on était en train d'échanger là par exemple avec Béat on est en train d'étudier nombre maintenant mais c'était lévitique un peu avant
et on voyait que même entre la famille des Lévis il y avait des divisions spécifiques pour que chacun puisse s'occuper des peu de choses mais avec beaucoup d'excellence
et donc c'est important cet environnement cette beauté
ces empreintes dans la croissance authentique de l'église
voilà les résultats ultimes de leurs contributions
et l'amour des dieux
et les empreintes du Christ dans leur service
comment Dieu communique son amour envers nous à travers les diacres envers la communauté
et comment Christ est perçu en nous servant à travers les diacres
ok
et donc c'est ce qu'on doit aspirer
car les diacres ils font la différence
qui peut lire ça
c'est juste un résumé de la fin du livre pour
rafraîchir notre compréhension du ministère diacronale
un passage très beau
oui
il s'appelle
avec une force
bien pas
le rapide
le service
est nécessaire
et leur équipement
c'est beau
hein